well one is that the best regime can be
made actual this has led to a world
revolutions in the 20th century and both
on the right and on the left the Nazis
on the Communists it also led to the
American Revolution which was not so
detrimental perhaps even a good thing
but a very moderate revolution that
substituted the rule of enlightened
Americans for the role of moderate
British imperialists so that was not as
as nasty and bloody a revolution as the
others what we live in our time and in
our country so it makes no sense to
condemn everything that we do or the
main things that we do as historically
mistaken we need to have a certain self
confidence that what we are about is
worth it and and and so I don't think we
should be overcome by our mistakes which
I think as a country are fewer than you
might find in say France or Britain or
Germany also very intelligent people